a dolphin carc is floating down a
tributary of Brazil's Amazon River more
than 100 IND dangered river dolphins
have died since last year when the
region was hit by an unprecedented
drought for months the natural climate
phenomenon in Nino has been blamed for
the decrease in rainfall causing rivers
to reach their lowest level in 120 years
but a study released this week found
that human activities such as
deforestation cattle ranching and
corporate farming have played a pivotal
role in reducing the Earth's capacity to
retain water the lack of precipitation
and high temperatures that lead to a
more evaporation and and drying even
more fast so we call this a drought that
is a agricultural ecological drought
then uh when we analyze that then uh a
climate change played a a much larger
role scientists site the the
unprecedented death of river dolphins to
make their case in the past they have
survived droughts but last year they
died because of the high water
temperatures the water temperature was
very high at the end of September when
70 dolphin cuses washed up in certain
moments the temperature exceeded
39° the average in the region of the
lake tefe is 29 to 31°
C the drought also affected more than
half million people living in Brazil and
other five South American countries they
depend on the rivers through
Transportation food and the delivery of
medical supplies scientists say this
drought is more widespread and has
affected the northern part of the Amazon
basin home to untouched areas of the
world's largest tropical forest in
regions where uh in the edge uh to the
South uh where the forest is already a
little bit more used to droughts then
they have some uh developed some some uh
um ways of be more resilient like say
have longer roots that goes deeper and
stuff like that but in this pristine
area they don't have so if we start
having droughts that reach this pristine
area uh the the forest can actually uh
uh be affected and we have the problem
of being a Tipping Point the solution
the study says is to stop burning fossil
fuels and reduce carbon emissions but
whether that will happen in time to
avoid future disasters remains to be
seen Monica yakiv Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer